the New York Times has reported that
Donald Trump wants to spend most of his
time at his New York penthouse rather
than the White House advisers told the
New York Times that Donald Trump wants
to spend weekends at Trump Tower maybe
at his New Jersey golf course or maybe
mar-a-lago his Resort in Florida the
most shocking sort of remark is actually
Trump not seeming to realize what is
involved in being president of the
United States a quote from this New York
Times article the questions that Donald
Trump asked President Obama reflect what
Trump's advisors described as the
president elects coming to grips with
the fact that his life is about to
radically change if you were just
realizing the scope of the job of
President of the United States
two days after you've been voted in when
you're talking to the current president
this is a red flag Pat we've got an
emergency here right we've always
questioned Donald Trump's work ethic it
seems like he likes to go around and
speak at rallies yeah but when it gets
to going through policy having to these
sort of cabinet meetings it just doesn't
seem interested in it no he doesn't and
I'm gonna get to that a little bit more
as far as Trump wanting to mostly spend
time places other than the White House
or partially spend time at places other
than the White House 2/7 or 3/7 of his
time elsewhere who's going to pay to
fortify Trump Tower or Moreau logo or
whatever the tax payers of course who's
going to pay for all the meetings that
would normally happen at the White House
but instead will require lawmakers to
travel to New York City or Florida or
this Golf Course in New Jersey taxpayers
of course fiscal conservatism right make
America great again and I'm sure it's
gonna be a security hazard too to have
the President of the United States in
the middle of Manhattan all the time
yeah the White House has a long
tradition of being a very secure area we
think about the Situation Room with all
the the tech that they have in the
underground tunnel system as well right
that's not gonna happen in Trump Tower
yeah Trump Tower now but the really
disturbing part isn't this this is just
sort of part of Trump's lack of
connection with the real world in terms
of what the job entails we have now
learned that Trump didn't really realize
what the President did until he met with
President Obama last week
and I been saying to friends did you see
those pictures when he came out of that
meeting when they were taking pictures
sitting in the Oval Office Trump really
looked shell-shocked and my thought was
this guy's realizing he's in over his
head it turns out that that was
absolutely true we have a report now
from The Wall Street Journal saying that
Donald Trump was quote surprised by the
scope of the president's
responsibilities well yeah and according
to The Wall Street Journal Trump's aides
were also unaware that the entire staff
of the president that works in the White
House West Wing would need to be
replaced I guess they thought the staff
came with the building or something I
know Trump has done untraditional
real-estate deals but everybody seemed
so clueless about what is going on here
and President Obama was criticized for
enjoying campaigning but not really
liking the work of dealing with other
people and presidenting just leaving a
word President Obama is going to strike
strike us as just the most epically
prepared guy going in compared to what
is going on with Donald Trump remember
though in spite of not knowing what the
president does we have to believe Trump
that he knows more about Isis than the
generals he knows more about the economy
than economists the reality is that
although many people are emailing me
saying I hope Trump quits number one
he's not going to quit but Mike Pence is
basically going to be President and that
is arguably much much worse than Donald
Trump being president because as we know
Mike Pence is actually far more
dangerous than Donald Trump Donald Trump
at at long last when when the the rubber
hits the road had similar positions to
Bernie Sanders on a number of issues
Mike Pence is a lunatic right-wing bomb
thrower who is off the rails on
basically every issue at least Trump is
sort of hinged I guess is the opposite
of unhinged on some issues very very
scary stuff the trumpeters they have no
clue they don't care they'll explain it
away because of how Great America is
going to be after Trump makes it that
way
Gamefly is sort of like Netflix for
video games they have over 8,000 new and
classic games for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4
ps3 Wii and a bunch of other platforms
and you can play as many games as you
want for one monthly fee
and if you find some games you want to
keep you can buy them for a low use
price there's never any due dates or
late fees and our audience can get a
free 30-day trial at Gamefly offer.com
slash TDP s the games are shipped
directly to you with return envelopes
included there's no contracts and you
can rent games through the mobile app
get the free 30-day trial for the David
Pakman show audience and support our
show by going to Gamefly offer.com slash
TDP s